the little princess asteroid b612 is
being orbited by a small body it has a
mass m and it goes around this asteroid
b612 that has a mass M one you know we
should add a coordinate system we always
know that our head goes radially outward
and we know from the universal law of
gravitation that we have mutual
attraction between these bodies and
actually that's going to point inward
and because we're having orbital motion
here so circular motion the acceleration
the radial component of the acceleration
will also point inward we need to
consider all of that for our F equals MA
analysis that we are going to do now
because the little prince'
wants to know how far this little body
is away from his asteroid okay so we
have the gravitational universal law
here minus G m1 over the distance
squared so the distance here between the
two planets R which is what we want to
calculate and then we have over here for
circular motion the description of M
Omega squared now the little prince'
can't measure omega but the little
prince has a little time clock so what
he can measure is the period from here
until he sees the body again and that is
2 PI over Omega so we can add that in
here M R 4 PI squared over T squared and
well there this M here will cancel out
and now we have to solve this for R what
we're going to see oh and of course we
have a minus sign here because in
life of the planer of the little prince
of course gravitational obv the
acceleration is not going outwards it's
going inward so we better give this a -
here and here as well and we will
actually see that that then cancels out
against this one and we're going to
solve this for R so we get R cubed
actually and then we have G 1 over 4 pi
squared and here we have a t squared and
you can also just write that as G 1 4 pi
squared T squared and then we have third
root so you might have seen this
equation here this actually Kepler's law
it describes the motion of the planets
around the Sun well it really only does
it if the motions are fairly circular
for elliptical orbits it is not such a
good approximation
although kepler derived it like that
quite quite a while ago and that was
really an astonishing result so here we
have this again that the cube of the
distance between two objects is
proportional to the square of the the
period of the orbiting time